the results for the Southwest Devon
constituent Sierra's follows I Tracey
Lee acting returning officer for the
election of the Member of Parliament for
the Southwest Devon constituency held on
the 8th of June 2017 do hereby declare
that the number of votes cast for each
candidate is as follows Philippa Devi
Devi labor and co-operative party 15800
M 18 Ian Ross UK Independence Party UK
1540 wind Scott Green Party 1133 Gary
Nicholas Streeter the Conservative Party
candidate 30 1634
Caroline Jane Bowdoin Liberal Democrat
2732 the number of rejected ballot
papers was 97 I therefore declare that
Gary Nicholas Streeter is duly elected
as a member of parliament for the
Southwest Devon constituency
well thank you very much indeed I'd like
to begin by thanking the acting
returning officer and all of her staff
for working so tremendously hard
throughout today and in the days leading
up to this election in all kinds of ways
thank you so much it's been a very
well-run account thank you for that I'd
like to thank the security we've had
this evening for the rather large police
officers we've had prowling around and
giving us reassurance that all is under
control thank you to our security
officers police and all
I like to thank all the other candidates
it's been they're gone it's been a very
hard fault but very fair election and I
think we've all become friends and I'm
hugely in favor of that kind of politics
I like thank all of my workers and
supporters from Southwest Devon and
particularly my agent Mike Zoltan who's
done an amazing job as always I'd like
to thank the people of Southwest Devon
for placing their confidence in me once
again and I pledge myself to work hard
for all of them however anybody has
voted to try and improve the lives of
everyone living in southwest Devon and
I'd like to finish on this point when I
ever I go and speak to schoolchildren
and talk about democracy I say to them
politicians can make speeches
politicians can bring forward policies
but in the end the power lies with the
people and I guess tonight we are seeing
another demonstration of that that the
people of this country have done
something that some of us didn't want
them to do but it's their choice in this
free democracy to do as they wish and
that's the Wonder and the joy of
democracy and long may it be so thank
you very much
[Applause]